so till here we go that I've got Oh baby
I'm gonna love you forever get you the
zone this is my new music right here and
the traffic okay let's pause it you
gotta get started welcome to the ask
Evan show episode number seven we're
here to talk about your questions help
some entrepreneurs out believe nation
here we go I'm starting with a question
for you guys this is Christina is not
gonna be happy with me I usually have
these orchids let me let me bring them
in these orchids in the picture and and
they're not blooming yet there's no
flowers just a stick and Christina said
we should take it out of the shot so I
want to know should the orchids be in
the shot or out of the shot and they're
not in the shot what should be there in
its place to leave a comment let me know
what you think I'll put them out of the
shot since it was a Christina request
and I love Christina but I want to know
what you guys think so let me know okay
good to the questions first one mens are
who is a newsletter subscriber love you
guys dear Evan I got my website created
to sell my products online please let me
know how I can make people to visit my
website please help regards mens are
awesome question and awesome great when
they start off the show everybody has
website right this is what this is a
problem that we all face a member when I
had my first website something I went
through how do i drive traffic to my
website get people to care there's a
couple ways to do it the the most basic
want is start creating content create
amazing content that is optimized for
search engines that make people feel
something if you have a website that is
boring that doesn't have a lot of text
on it you're not going to get a lot of
people coming right the search engine
traffic will drive people there if you
have a lot of content the quality of the
content will keep people there and get
people sharing it tell their friends
about it so if you visit your website
what do I see am I inspired is a lot of
content on there are you sharing a
powerful opinion on top of that use the
media when I was first getting started
nobody knew Evan Carmichael nobody knew
who I was nobody was it in my website
you know you got a couple hundred
visitors and you're on
up on the moon I reached out to the
media and I made a list of all the major
media that covered my industry New York
Times Forbes Wall Street Journal and I
reached out to them every week with a
new story and not just that hey I'm
great Evan Carmichael I have all these
opinions and views trump check out my
website it's not promotional because me
doesn't care about that you have to give
them a story so create a story and fill
it with facts and arguments and with
every story you need to have an expert
opinion on it so I would be that expert
the more work you do to help a reporter
out this is their job right you're
saving them time and energy that makes
it easier for them to write a story
about you and get noticed and it worked
for me as I said got into all those
publications and then once you get one
its no balls and people see all you've
been in new york time so i want to
interview you too and it keeps growing
and every time you want to make sure
that they're listing your name and your
website in the credits to help drive
traffic to your site good luck next is a
question that I have can I ask my own
question on my show I think I can Jason
what do you think definitely right it's
my show I get to pick the rules okay so
good dear Evan from Evan here's my
question I saw this great video on
YouTube about these two guys who were
doing a blind taste test competition
they were they thought they could
identify hamburgers so they went out and
got hamburgers from all the five
different hamburger stores blindfolded
and then went up against each other to
do the taste test I'll try to find that
video so we could we could popped up in
the side view guys to see and then they
started switching up the burger so they
had the meat from one burger and the bun
from the other burger and the toppings
from another burger and they ate it and
they had to they had to vote and figure
out which which one came from where and
and they made huge mistakes and they
weren't even close I most of them and I
thought that'd be a cool kind of fun
different video to make so I want to
know how that can kind of relate to my
channel and entrepreneurship it could be
a contest me against somebody else
something fun something a little off the
wall something to make you laugh if you
guys have ideas leave it in the comments
below because I want to hear it you
should I answer questions on the show
but I can't answer the question get this
my own question so switching up the
rules a little bit let me know what you
guys think all right next up Demaryius
who's on my
newsletter list love you guys he writes
in I've always had a dream that I'll be
singing or rapping just like wiz khalifa
I mean after all you can see the lion in
me I love music I when I'm in the zone I
feel good I feel honestly I'm doing what
I'm supposed to do but how can I get to
that level I believe but now I just want
to see so Demaryius I want you to start
modeling success man I want you to start
getting out there I want you to look at
Wiz Khalifa look at mmm look at these
guys who look up to and how they got
started and leverage out success and put
it to work for you I put up this great
clip a while ago Christina let's pop
that booty up for for des meeres to
check out of mm crank calling in to a
show that LL Cool J was on and LL Cool J
was his mentor mm crank called in
pretending to be somebody else and
started rapping right started showing
off his chops and they didn't know who
he was but he said hey man you're really
good you should you should have your own
record you should get out there and
promote yourself because his talent was
obvious right if your talent is obvious
if you're really good if you're as good
as Wiz Khalifa right you have your own
little style and and you're awesome at
it then you got to start getting out you
should be called in the shows you should
be doing competitions Eminem was
struggling doing competition after
competition never gotten noticed until
you went to the rap Olympics and not put
him on the map you won second place that
got him into to meet dr. Dre and that
got his career started right these are
the things that you got to be doing you
got to be out there hustling rapping
every day making videos doing
collaborations calling in the show's
joining competitions if you love singing
you got to pour your heart into it model
success find these guys you love look at
what made them successful apply it to
your wrapping crew or two and I want to
hear a believe track yo Demaryius drop
some believe lyrics for me I want to
hear it and if they're good bro they're
going to be in the next video okay use
your chance let's see what you got next
up Felix another newsletter subscriber
the newsletter love is coming on strong
in today's episode he writes in hi Evan
can I have a chat on turning five
thousand two hundred thousand five
thousand to a hundred thousand kind
regards Felix all right you want to make
money that's the question of the day
okay this is one of the most important
lessons in business mine
it comes from providing value it's
simple bro you want to get a lot of
money you got to provide a lot of guy
you want a lot of money quickly you got
to provide a lot of value quickly
whether your goal is to make a hundred
thousand a million a billion whatever it
is you make money by providing value so
what you need to do is find something
that you're passionate about something
that excites you something that you can
help change the world with that will
help a lot of people and when those
things cross over when you can combine
something that you love doing something
you're excited about with something that
helps people in a real meaningful solid
way that's your path to success that's
your path to riches and I focus less on
the money the people who focus just on
the money they don't make it you look at
the successful enterprise and you don't
see them my goal is to make a hundred
thousand dollars or to make a
million-dollar right that's not what
they're there to do money is a byproduct
of doing something important to focus on
your passion focus on what you love
doing focus on how you can help other
people in a really strong meaningful way
and if you are providing crazy value to
people the money will follow I promise
alright last question of the day already
we're at five it's crazy how fast it
goes a loyal YouTube viewer game ova
thank you so much for the questions
always this one comes up this is a
really important one so it's about
mediocrity says I like this video but
mediocrity is a habit of mine how do you
remind yourself to create a supportive
environment in the first place this is
great because you wake up and often your
schedule is just on autopilot your
morning routine is on autopilot and it
doesn't support you or serve you and
when you have these moments in your life
when you realize he I could be a lot
more I could step out a mediocre I want
to follow this bold idea I want to
change something start right now right
at this video right here inspires you to
want to do something different then
start that plan now don't wait till
tomorrow morning to start start it right
now one of the things i recommend doing
for creating the supportive environment
is music you start your day with music
at the top of the show I had Randy
Travis going I'm singing along I don't
know how much Christina's going to
include hopefully a good chunk of that
you guys get to experience this terrible
voice but it got me in the zone I got me
excited I'm flying through this I'm
loving it I'm feel
Randy Travis energy right music you got
to put that in there so you know that's
going to be part of your plan to create
a supportive environment and have music
around you start your playlist right now
I make a believe playlist rainy Chavez
that was the newest song on it on there
make your own playlist make a belief
playlist call it believed and start
adding the songs into it right now I
talked about having a big y and having
you little wise and everything that I
put on that video start thinking about
right now and then make it easy for you
to be able to launch into that tomorrow
make it easy right so you can create
your playlist in YouTube save it there
leave it on your computer as the as the
reminder and then the next morning when
you wake up boom it's right there I've
created a homepage dashboard on my
computer that basically lists everything
that I have to go through so i have my
playlist there i have mine I have my you
know YouTube comments I have everything
I look at every day that I designed so
as soon as I have my computer boom I'm
there you want to make it super easy
it's like any other habit that you're
trying to build make it easy so if you
want to if you want to be a runner right
you want to run in the morning get your
shoes in your gear already and put it
right by the door so you wake up you see
your shoes you don't have any excuses to
say hey I gotta get my shoes I gotta get
change and I'll do all this stuff all
those things that may seem little but
hold you back make it easy prepare the
night before and you're set up for
success and as soon as you have that
idea to step outside to do something
bolder bigger change your life in some
way take immediate action right now do
something small to move that stick a
little bit further because that builds
momentum that you can carry forward for
the next day the next day the rest of
your life believe those are you guys
watching up at another show it's fast I
came to come fast these things fly I
love you guys thank you so much to the
questions you want to be on the ask
Kevin show with your question leave a
comment below and let me give video
response thank you so much subscribe to
the channel see more just like this and
I'll see you soon beginning in the end
ya may think that I'm talking foolish to
third and wild and I'm free don't forget
to click here to subscribe to my
newsletter to get actionable inspiring
motivational believe advice every single
week to your inbox hi I'm Jason j-rod
fonseka of ra's online com and i want to
say Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring XD only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period